Hello, everybody!  My name is Markiplier.(I KNOW)
There seems to be a common misconception(????)
that Tyler,
this guy, right here,(☉_☉)
this guy, Tyler,(͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
this guy.
Look at him spinning and doing backflips WTF????
and stuff like that.
Tyler **GOD**
Oh man, his–his head just exploded!¯\_(ツ)_/¯
Oh, now he's a ghost! DA FWQ
That guy, Tyler.
There's a common misconception that HE'S my editor ok??
and you'd be
ABSOLUTELY
**RIGHT!**
He is 100% **my editor* and I wanna show off
all of his most** -AMAZING- **editing skills possible.
And there's only one way to celebrate, and that's to release the
BALLOOOOOONS!
WHOOAA!!
There's so many and so many colors!
There's every single color...balloon
that the human mind can comprehen- (pause)
Tyler is NOT my editor.
Ethan and Kathryn, are my editors.
And I, even edit my own stuff!
Amy also edits and makes stuff in After Effects.
But Tyler, has never touched Premiere
a day in his life.
Today, we're gonna change that.
I want to point out...
This is not a punishment.
Even if he may think it's a punishment,
we just wanna encourage skill building
among our friends. Right?
We wanna encourage people to grow
both as professionals and as people.
And uh, just because
we worked for 36 hours straight
on "A Date with Markiplier"
and he went home and slept
and then came back in the morning and didn't even
have the common courtesy to get us coffee
does not mean that it's a punishment.
We love him. And if you love your
children...throw'em in the deep end of the pool.
Hi, i'm Tyler. Born and
raised in Cincinnati, Ohio.
I grew up kind a with mark to an extent
and uh...
uh
I'm 28. Uh, I've never edited.
anything video-wise before
I can't wait to cheer him on!
uh, and definitely not judge
his editing skills! (sarcasm)
It's gonna be really great,
I can't wait to see our little butterfly
fly...away...
Hi, I'm Kathryn.
I do a lot...I do most of the editing
for Mark.
So, when we first had this idea...
We were gonna give Tyler a crash course.
Now, I've been offering to give Tyler
a crash course in Premier, on how to
edit Marks videos...but every time I bring
it up, he's like "Nah..we-we'll do it later".
And so I just wanna help! (starts laughing)
Here he is. I was gonna- i was gonna show him
how to do all the basics.
And he just- he kept putting it off.
And now it's-it's here.
The time has come and I'm just
it hurts to watch, honestly. (laughing)
Mark: So
Go ahead.
Tyler: K...
Mark: Oh wait, before I do that I
uh, want you to know...
that you are being timed.
See this big clock over here? Right here?
Mark: You see this? You see this thing?
Mark: See that Tyler?
Ready?
Mark: I wanna-I wanna point out
This isn't an unfair time!
Tyler: Ho-hold on!
Tyler: Am I allowed to open the applica...
Mark: No!
If this is this time is specifically
meant, because WE-
-as editors
when we were making "A Date with Markiplier", we
roughly did about 24 videos
in 36 hours, which works out
to everyone doing a video at every 2 hours or so.
And that sounds pretty fair, right?
I think so.
Mark: I even gave you an extra second!
Tyler: New project (chuckles)
Mark: Wow! What are you going to call it?
*silence*
Wasting precious time on the name! This is-this is-
Yeah. Not so sure.
Mark: Yeah, cause you wanna make sure all your assets
are in the same place. So if someone else
has to open the project...
all the assets aren't just on your computer.
Know what I mean?
Or in a different folder with different projects.
I hate you all.
Mark: Whooaaa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Tyler: You don't need to whoa
We're here, right by your side
Mark: *air kisses Tyler's head*
Tyler: eugh!
Tyler: That...I felt that on my hair...
Mark: "I hate you all"...?
Pretty strong words for uh
a friend
to say...ya know? But!
To his credit,
he did open a project.
He did import the footage.
But which are the 2 easiest steps
and take like five seconds to do...
And he did it in, 5 minutes. *Silence*
*clears throat*
Ethan: So do you know what that is?
Everything there? Tyler: Yeah! you've got
the audio, you've got the actual visual.
Ethan: No, but I'm talking about this thing here.
Tyler: Thats-thats your timeline
Ethan: Good good! Okay!
Mark: *whispers* He's learning!
Tyler: I have no freakin clue!
Please, please let me set this up!
Nope!
Please! This isn't even the editing part.
No, not 720.
You got...I can't just give it to you Tyler!
I can! (Mark laughing)
Should we just set it up for him?
Please! Please! Can I do-can I do what I was supposed to do?
You've got the footage and you've got the gameplay.
And they're 2 separate things. You've done it!
Good!
Mark: He's learning...
Ethan: He's learning!
Mark: He's learning.
At the very basic,
this is gonna be a "Let's Play" like I did
a few years ago!
Uh huh!
No edits. But, correct format!
Haha!
Is he getting it?
Ah! Yes!
*whispers* He's getting it!
Ethan: Are you a proud papa?
Mark: Huh? He's older than I am.
Ethan: oh...
*Ethan and Mark gasping*
Ethan: Tyler!
Mark: Tyler!
Ethan: You're getting it!
Tyler: This looks like enough space.
Im sweating!
Im legitimately sweating
because they are stressing me the hell out!
Ethan! Is talking to me like
im a freakin child! *cries*
I'm not your child, I'm older than you!
Baby boy! Baby boy blue!
And the timer is countin down!
Right in front of me as I'm doin this!
Tyler: I think I'm learning pretty quick.
So, i'm kinda proud of myself.
Imma give myself a pat on the back
and try not to stress out more
then that TIMER NEEDS TO STOP!
Mark!...Stop the timer.
Why?
Please? This-I'm not editing right now.
So?
You should be!
I asked you if you wanted to say
some words (laughing) you said "Yes!"
Do you want me to give you a quick crash course?
Yes!
Oh, Okay!
You wanna activate--
Hold on. This is a crash course I can't get around
cause, I-I can't learn by watching it.
I have to do.
Okay, so!
*Mark and Ethan chuckling*
You're gonna hit B2
you wanna activate that video track.
(laughing) He has to "Do"
*gasping* You don't teach Tyler
Tyler teaches YOU!
*Mark and Ethan Laughing*
Mark: *laughing* Tyler teaches...
Mark:..TYLER!
*both laughing*
Kathryn: They let me give Tyler
the crash course
that I was suppost to give him
a couple days ago
I think he's gonna do
a really good job!
He's really excited about it...
I think the biggest..
-the biggest thing against him
right now-
is the clock.
And...uh..
Ethan.
Ethan: Uhh...
I think Tyler's doing..
pretty good so far. *sarcasm*
Ethan: Uhhh.. y'know
..he's got the..beginning stuff down..?
Ethan: Uhh.. I'm excited to see
his fancy edits.
Cause' he says that he..
..has..uhh
..ideas!...
Ummmmmm
..and...
..I'm also worried..
that after this he's just gonna be like
Ohhhh.. *snap* *clap*
"EDITING'S EASY!"
"IT'S THE EASIEST THING IN THE WORLD"
*chuckling* because..
He walked into the bathroom and said..
"YEAH!"
"I'm a- I'm a- I'm learning real-
real quick! And it's a..
-it's not that bad.
And then Kathryn was like...
"Yeah, but this is the easiest part of the editing."
So...
I'm excited to see..
uh...w-what else he has to say
*chuckling* about himself!
Mark: I'm kind of noticing a power dynamic
..going on here.
Ethan is alot more threatened
..then I thought he'd  be by Tyler.
A-and admittedly,
he has picked up quick.
The clock is against him
and he's only got about an..an hour 15 minutes left.
Uhh but...yeah..Ethan, umm...
..I think all of his criticisms
are coming across.. as like..
Defensive...
'Cause...
What if Tyler's better than him?
...
*quietly* I-I don't need 3 editors...
Five! Four! Three! Two! One! *Ethan makes buzzer noise*
Put down your pencils!
*Mark in background*
*Ethan and Mark repeatedly yelling "Tyler"*
Cheaters NEVER Win!
Kathryn: You're like Tom Brady...
Ethan: Tyler...
Mark: PUT YOUR PENCILS DOWWNN!
Ethan: That mouse is looking rather ?deflated?
*Mark & Ethan laughing*
Ethan: You're cheating! *still laughing*
Alright, well...
...shall we all watch?
Kathryn: Yeah! Viewing party!
Alright, alright.
WoaH WOAH! Get outta here
Ronnie the Rhino! You're not
You're not welcome here!
I'm a firm believer that anyone can do anything if they put their mind to it!
Show an info graphic..
of...
..everyone! of-of-of
..of-of the cumulative..
human, th-thinking....
...power...process?
Like...get a..like a..
like a diagram!
That perfectly represents human thinking!
RIGHT HERE!!
*pause*
AAAAHHHHHH!
So I'm gonna do a very simple let's play..
and
It's very convienent
that there's no internet
because, I dunno if you guys knew this...
umm..
this is actually a game!
If you have no internet,
and you're running out of internet
uhhh, you can just play a game.
So, I'm just gonna play this...
and, uhh..
Tyler's..just gonna edit it!
and he's gonna do a great jo-  *loud ass beep*
..HUH! Fucking...
...fucking. FUCK!
Why did that scare me!? *laughing*
oh jeez...Okay, anyway!
*scream*
OH GOD! WHAT SCARED ME WITH A WEREWOLF!?
WOAAHHH!
*awkward silence*
Now what- what's really cool with this game is
once you get 100 points...
uhh..
a laser light show starts
from the ground up
and then shoots as dubstep music plays
in the background.
Ok, so i hit 100 points there...you didn't see a lot of it
but this time it's- w-when the 3rd time you get 100 points...
...instead of dubstep and a laser show...
its FIREWORKS exploding..
..an EAGLE swooping in..
and then BANGIN house music
mixed with a little bit of pop! -is coming in there...
Oh!
Hang on, wait!
While i'm playing this.. *drops something*
eh FUCK
While i'm playing this it-it- it's very interesting because
if you- if you're playing, and you get 100 points...
you need to shoot..a gun..
in the air..
and squeal like a...
BANG!
WOAH! The realistic gun effect!
It's a real gun, guys!
fuck!
So watch, watch again.
Now...uh..every-every uh..every 10 points after 100
once the laser light show and the dubstep house musi-
*game dings*
bANG!
BANG!
BANG!!
BANG!!!
With every jump-
BANG!
and then CONFETTI RAINS FROM THE CEILING
..BANG!
Oh! Wait! Down there in the- in the field-
-just below this...
there a parade of like...
...hundreds of different coloured of Elephants!
Look at 'em all go!
I can hardly count...
BANG!
I can hardly count how many there are...
I ca-I can't- How many? One, a hundred,
Twenty-five, twenty-seven,
oOH! Fish! Flowing in a river!
Oh my god, is it RAINING in here?!
Holy shit, it's going nuts in MY house.
OK, alright, anyway, enough of that.
It's gonna calm down-it's gonna-this game is really crazy guys!
We need to-we need to step it down a little bit.
Because I need to get a high score because that's what I do!
I play games good and well and uh,
NEVER BADLY.
Here comes a comical zoom-up/close-up of my face, with weird proportioned body parts!
*fake chuckle* Wasn't that funny guys? Yeah, that was pretty funny wasn't it?
Here comes another zoom-up! Of my face! With.. something else hilarious happening to me!
Heh. Wasn't that a good one? WAIT, ONE MORE?!
Ah, man. That Tyler, he's such a good editor.
Yeah I have no idea what he's doing here, I'm just-
-just bizarre that we have all these random occurrences are coming in the way of my...
...perfectly normal and understandable Let's Play.
It's-It's really interesting because once I beat my high score of three hundred,
uh, what'll actually happen is: the whole game and video cuts away to uh, Tyler crying in a bathtub.
That's just like, an ancillary fact.
I don't know what that has to do with this game, but I mean..
It just happens, the Google programmers written it in there like that.
Okay, alright... huh.
I-I-I think the game might've calmed down a little-AYEYEOH.
That pterodactyl.. ohh duh-duh-duh-duh.
Okay NOW I'm actually concentrating on this so I hope-
I hope nothing ELSE crazy happens while I'm-
WHAT IS THAT!? OH NO!
I HOPE THEY DON'T GET IN THE WAY OF MY SCORE!
IT'S A COMPETING DINOSAUR-woah okay then.
Alright apparently It's night now...
MAKE MY WEBCAM NIGHT TOO!
Get some cricket sound effects in there!
Ohh is it a starry night or is it a cloudy night?
Is it a full moon? I don't know...
OH SHIT! Well apparently it's day now....
Alright scratch all that
Alright bring in the dancing girls one at a time
Hundreds of them down at the bottom...blah...
Just going for it there lovely they are
WOW!
Okay alright
Now suddenly the game to start turning multiple colors all at the same time
The music is going to slowly pitch shift down
OH SHIT!  MORE BALLOONS I'M GETTING THE ULTIMATE HIGH SCORE
HOLY FUCK
Hip
Yupe
Blurp
Blupe
bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop, oh boy
Now I'm actually legitimately concentrating because I...
Kinda like
This is getting interesting now
Ok now ignore all the craziness that happened before because that has nothing to do with me
Getting this ultimate high score... why is it shifting
Like how fast is that day, oh FUCKING
FUCK
AHHHHHH LOOK HOW FUNNY IT WHEN I'M EDITING ANGRY
I'M TURNING INTO THE HULK
*wimpy noises*
Ok so anyway that was Tyler's first video that he has ever made
Wow wasn't that amazing
Now that showcases the skill
And power and vim and vigor of everybody
Who helps me make my videos
But in all honesty,  Kathryn and Ethan both help make my videos
In addition to myself I do alot of editing myself
But they have taken on the brunt of the work
So I can focus on making cool videos myself and getting new ideas out there
And all together like we have a really good team and I'm really happy
That I have so many people that are willing to try new things
And help me out in making these cool videos
And coming with me with my crazy and stupid ideas and coming up with their own crazy, stupid ideas like
I'm honored to have them apart of this
And I'm super happy that they're here
And you know I-I wouldn't be here without them so I-I
So I would have to say that I'm super grateful to Tyler
Ethan, Kathryn, and Amy for all, helping me you know
With what I do and all and making so that you guys get better videos so
At the end of the day that is what really matters *outro song plays*
Thank you everyone for so much for watching I hope you enjoy this and if you want to see Tyler do something else
I'm going to have him make a animation for me how's that sound?
I don't know maybe something like that
But If you have an Idea leave it in the comments below
But thank you everyone so much for watching
And as always, I will see you, in the next video, BYE BYE!
*music slows down creepily*
So, Tyler did better than I thought he would if he had taken the crash course before this venture
He may have been able to put more detail into the edits that he did
But for what they were, like, conceptually they were there
He was able to track motion, key frame stuff, place it correctly, crop it out,  green screen
Like not bad, I mean I would've made the  game, the actual game video bigger so people
See it and not be a tiny quarter of the screen
But you know to each their own
So thank you everybody so much for watching hope you enjoy this little video and a...
As always,  we'll see you, in the next video
BYE BYE!
I wasn't paying attention, it kinda looked like shit.
I was too busy working.